[WIND BLOWING]
(SINGING) When we met, I was
younger than a young thing
can be.
(SINGING) You were wet.
You were hungry.
You still needed me.
You said I could
fly, and I flew.
I remember before you knew--
You taught me--
--how to talk--
--now I talk like you do.
You taught me to see, not to
see but to really look deeper
like you do--
I already knew you'd leave me
someday with no cure for love
that I had from the
moment I heard--
--and from my--
--your first word--
Mama.
You shaped the boy I become,
but the boy disappeared
lost to the years--
And the man you became
is a beautiful one,
every bit still the same,
every bit still my son.
But, oh, here we go with our
words and the battle's begun.
And when the dust settles, I'm
sick as I see what I've done.
If I could just tell you
that you more than deserved
those three little
words I can't find.
There is no other one--
--you are my mother--
--you are my son--
--you are mine.
At times you rile me up just a
little bit, more than most do.
You get on my nerves, and
I'm sure that I get on yours.
Surely, we both do.
Aren't we supposed to
say what we're feeling?
Instead, I'm concealing my
heart and just offering guile.
And when you smile,
it's my reflection.
Mixed with everything I fear--
all of my flaws--
look what I've caused to appear.
Why can't I say what
you most need to hear?
Don't leave me stuck
in the dark, dear.
Oh, here we go with our
words, and the battle's begun.
And when the dust settles, I'm
sick as I see what I've done.
If I could just tell you
that you more than deserved
those three little
words I can't find.
There is no other one--
--you are my mother--
--you are my son--
--you are mine.
If I could just tell you that--